this is like my favorite topic hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be doing a deep
dive into the infamous diet of the
Gilmore Girls but first let me tell you
what my sponsor June's Journey so
everyone who knows me knows that I love
a good murder mystery I've exhausted all
of my options on Netflix for True Crime
so as I was waiting for something new to
watch I discovered June's Journey on my
phone so this is a really cool Hidden
Object murder mystery game that's set in
the 1920s and it's available for free on
any Android or Apple mobile device or
also on your desktop through Amazon or
Facebook so I heard about this through a
friend and apparently it has a huge
following they have over 30 million
people playing it worldwide so I've
never really been a gamer per se but I
got really into this game because it
requires good critical thinking skills
it has a solid storyline and it's got
beautiful colorful Graphics set in the
Glamorous 1920s it's definitely a nice
distract action after a really busy
hectic stressful day and it's a nice
active alternative to let's say just
watching TV so if you want to try out
June's Journey yourself you can click
the link in the description and you can
download it on your iOS or your Android
mobile devices or through Facebook games
on your PC and you can pause the screen
or look at the description to check out
my disclaimer including a trigger
warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating so as always feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive to
your journey thanks to my family for
bringing all the viruses into my home
I'm channeling my inner Louis Armstrong
today
laughs
what a wonderful way let's make it a
Vibe but if you're new here please hit
that subscribe button and follow me over
on Tick Tock and Instagram at Abby's
kitchen also a quick shout out to the
Creator Jessica Viana who reminded me of
my own interest in the Gilmore Girls
diet so please be sure to watch her
video on this topic as well but fun
little factoid when I was starting my
Graduate Studies in sociology my first
major research project was actually
looking at shows like the Gilmore Girls
and their representation of female
protagonists diets so this topic is
actually very near and dear to my heart
but if you've watched my channel you
know that I'm usually needing to be
critical of social media and pop culture
content that celebrates and normalizes
thin women engaging in restrictive
disorderly eating behaviors in the name
of Purity clean eating or Wellness but
what about when we flip the script to
celebrate only eating junk well let's
talk about the originator of this trend
the cool girl Trope and how it relates
to every millennial's favorite Duo the
Gilmore Girls so the Gilmore Girls was
my first personal introduction to the
cool girl Trope on TV which was also
exemplified by characters like that 70s
Show's Donna Rachel in Forgetting Sarah
Marshall and there's something about
Mary's namesake Mary but basically the
cool girl archetype portrays women as
being just like one of the guys based on
how they dress how they eat their
interests and hobbies while
simultaneously being smoking hot and
effortlessly thin in the case of the
Gilmore Girls the cool girl narrative is
dominated by the mother-daughter Duo's
signature eating habits
I don't see how you do it but you're not
us are you oh ice cream oh I'm right
behind you
could they possibly eat more their love
of food hatred of exercise and ability
to eat a large quantity of food and not
gain any weight is a central Quirk of
these characters throughout the series
what are we if not world champion eaters
it's too much food and while the thin
hot girl with the miracle metabolism is
not a mythical creature of course they
do exist the expectation and pressure on
young women and girls to embody it
themselves at any cost is frustrating at
best and dangerous at worst to give you
more specifics let's look at what the
Gilmore Girls characters allegedly eat
toward themselves their cool girl titles
well according to a series of online
food Diaries chronicling everything that
Rory and Lorelei eat on every single
episode breakfast is usually some
variation or combination of eggs scones
pancakes french toast or muffins from
Luke's Diner I'll have poached eggs but
in the meantime we get some eggs and
bacon and hash browns to tie this over
snacks include Donuts candy or another
kind of baked good or dessert the
classic Gilmore Girl lunch is a big
burger and fries and dinner will usually
include Chinese food takeout pizza or if
it's home cooked a big pot roast supper
the girls are also well known for their
love of coffee which they consume
frequently throughout the day obviously
there are a ton of variations throughout
the series so please don't come at me
for missing like your favorite meal in
the series but from what I've read it
does seem like these are some of the
Heavy Hitters on rotation now because my
YouTube feed is generally bombarded with
influencers tatting the benefits of but
first let me tell you what my sponsor
June's Journey so everyone who knows me
knows that I love a good murder mystery
I've ex it's often a breath of fresh air
to see an adult eat eight normal
unrestrained meal and based on law
Pop-Tart monologue it does seem that her
character lives on fast food because her
diet was actually so restrained by her
mother side note this is why we don't
put kids on diets regardless of the
character's backstory does that mean
that we should be glorifying the other
dietary extreme go boysenberry pie with
ice cream hot fudge sundae have a
grapefruit it's good for you as you can
imagine a big bowl of greens or a piece
of fruit or anything that's good for you
is not exactly compatible with the cool
girl Vibe it's diety it's rigid it's not
very fun but never eating a vegetable is
also naughty normal balanced way for an
adult to eat and only eating junk food
to fit the cool girl Vibe is equally as
problematic and arguably disorderly as
eliminating all junk food in the day to
fit the that girl Vibe and this brings
me to how the cool girl Trope has
evolved from the early 2 thousands on
shows like Gilmore Girls to the
performance of intuitive eating on
today's social media and reality TV one
of the common criticisms of the 2000s
show was that were fed this narrative
that the girls love to eat and do so
with Unapologetic food freedom but we
don't usually see them actually eat wow
we see them talk about food we see them
prepare food we see the food being
served we see the food being played with
but we don't actually get to see food
being eaten or enjoyed and if we do it's
usually just a bite and I get it this is
a sitcom not Food Network the food is
largely just a prop I'm also well aware
that it's often best practice on TV or
movie shoots for actors to chew and then
spit out their food between tanks pseudo
disorderly perhaps but this is just what
actors do apparently however most young
teens or adults watching don't realize
that the foods are just a prop and we
see these characters as as real women
real fun women who can eat burgers and
fries with the guys every day but who
perhaps look like society would expect
to just order a salad with Seltzer and
we can take this one step further when
the characters are in fact real well at
least allegedly so think about the
Kardashians The Bachelor and selling
Sunset all of which I mindlessly yet
religiously watch without any guilt or
shame in every episode of selling Sunset
we see the women order fries burrata
pizza cupcakes cocktails and other high
calorie foods at their meetings or dates
yet we mostly see these food items just
like sit there untouched likewise the
food scenes in the Kardashian show also
often feature a higher calorie kind of
fun Foods even though these women have
been frequently quoted in real life as
living off of green juice and like just
straight up protein and the women on The
Bachelor franchise also are rarely seen
eating on any of their dates and we also
can't forget about the OG reality Queen
Paris Hilton's Infamous Carl's Jr
commercials as well as her recent
cooking series where she prepares
lasagna cannolis fries and Cake
essentially what these scenes are doing
are reinforcing a brand image of the
cool girl who can reject diet culture
enjoy life at all of its delicious
Pleasures while fending off any rumors
that their figures are the result of
intense body manipulation under eating
or even disordered eating remember these
days dieting is out Wellness is in can I
get amen up in here and eating
intuitively is also in Vogue and we as
consumers buy into it providing that
it's really not that hard to perform
intuitive eating and interact with these
Foods by proximity without repercussions
for their Hollywood bodies and there's
nothing wrong with having a thin
socially desirable body in my opinion
everyone is entitled to body autonomy so
whether these starlets or characters are
naturally thin than by dieting or thin
by surgery it is really not my business
to judge you do whatever makes you happy
but I do worry that this frequent Trope
reinforces the pressure that we see on
women to achieve a likely impossible
Behavior to outcome in their
relationship with food and I'll tell you
why remember if we go back to the
Gilmore Girls for like a hot minute
being thin serves as a justification for
their eating behaviors it's quirky it's
fun it's cute I'm like but being a
self-proclaimed Champion eater would be
perceived very differently by the public
if their bodies were a different size or
shape intuitively eating In and Out
Burgers every day is only sexy to the
public when you're thin now I've talked
about this on my channel before I've
reviewed a number of folks in larger
bodies who've been the subject of
intense bullying and non-stop criticism
for the food that they eat meanwhile
creators who put out similar or
significantly more problematic mukbang
cheat day or binge-like food content are
viewed much more positively this is to
assume that these behaviors are not
unhealthy because the outcome is a body
that is thin in fact I compared the
comment section of always hungry at
amberlynn Reed and found exactly that
another great example of this double
standard in the media was back in 2020
when rapper sawidi posted a McDonald's
mukbang on Instagram live and many
people were quick to point out that if
lizzo had done the exact same thing she
would have received a dramatically
different response simply just because
of the size of her body and I discussed
this in my video on lizzo right here she
has been repeatedly fat chained for her
body size despite having a very active
lifestyle following a vegan diet and
maintaining an overall healthy and
varied relationship with food
interestingly if we bring it back to the
girls for a hot minute it's worth
pointing out that the show hasn't
exactly aged well in the age of body
positivity the characters are notorious
for their inappropriate fat shaming
one-liners can't we find some other
really fat people to watch even the 2016
Revival received criticism for a bunch
of its gross fat phobic comments Ellie
alert lots of returning favorites today
why there's old butter butt and our good
friend Back Fat Pat this is so so not
cute so what are we as a society
actually concerned about when it comes
to other people's eating behaviors is it
their health outcomes or is it their
weight because just a quick reminder
that health is absolutely not synonymous
with weight in fact we have research to
suggest that engaging in healthy
behaviors is a far better predictor of
Health than any outcome we may see on
the scale one prospective study even
found that metabolically healthy folks
with a high BMI had a reduced risk of
all cause mortality whereas
metabolically unhealthy folks with a
normal BMI were at a greater risk of
cardiovascular mortality yet somehow
despite the mounting evidence weight
bias continues to influence our
perception of healthy behaviors yeah
some days you just over it
finally I want to chat about the message
that shows like this portray about a
healthy relationship with food as I
briefly mentioned consuming convenience
foods and like recoiling at the mere
thought of physical activity or a piece
of fruit doesn't support long-term
Health it's also not a great message for
young viewers at home to hear that
eating vegetables and like moving your
body are not cool girl things to do
again portraying a healthy relationship
with food in the media is complicated as
[ __ ] and it would also be triggering and
problematic to show a thin protagonist
as only eating salads and drinking
Seltzer but if we want our youth to grow
up to have balanced relationships with
food we need to show them relatable
protagonists having balanced
relationships with food that could mean
eating a burger one meal and like a
salad the next having a cookie with
dinner and a smoothie with pancakes for
breakfast eating sugar gluten and dairy
but also avocado toast green juice and
water why do we have to insist on
glorifying the extremes when we all know
that moderation as unfucking sexy as it
may be is actually what works so to
summarize it's no surprise that the
Gilmore Girls misses the mark on
portraying a healthy relationship with
food speaking for myself I know that
watching the show definitely sent some
mixed messages about how I should look
and eat should I be eating large
quantities of candy pizza and burgers so
that I can look cool like Rory and
Lorelei and what does it mean if my body
changes but my idols on my TV screen
remain the same size as an adult and
nutrition professional today I can now
see the holes in this Trope and I can
see the deceitful performance of
intuitive eating online ultimately the
more that we fixate on what we see
online or on television to inform how we
should look eat and move the harder it
will be for us to figure out what
genuinely feels good to us so on that
note that is all that I have for you
guys today thank you again to June's
Journey for sponsoring this video if you
want to check it out yourself you can
click the link in the description and
download it on your Android or your iOS
mobile devices or through Facebook games
on your PC if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on who or what you'd like
to see me review next subscribe to the
channel and I will see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
good
[Music]